benoît martin secrétaire de l'union
départementale cgt parisse bonsoir
benoît martin merci d'être avec nous sur
rt france on le voit avec la loi
d'urgence
il y à des efforts qui sont demandés à
tous les salariés français
que pensez vous de cette injonction
faite par bruno le maire ne pas y aller
mollo sur les dividendes donc c'est un
peu ça l'idée
oui et non nous pensons qu'il faut
arrêter les dividendes ne pas verser de
dividende aux actionnaires dans les
périodes qui qui se profile lancement
par exemple de rendement l'entreprise
orange et bien le qu'en dira le conseil
d'administration s'apprête à verser aux
actionnaires à peu près deux milliards
et demi d'euros
en ce moment et donc pour réclamant par
exemple dans l'entreprise mais également
dans toutes les autres que les
dividendes ne soient pas versées que
l'argent conservé dans les entreprises
pour amortir les effets le choc de cette
crise qui n'est pas qu'ils crise
sanitaire mais qui va être aussi une
crise économique et sociale
et vous pensez qu'il ya besoin de ses
dividendes justement pour pouvoir verser
les salaires aux personnes qui sont en
chômage technique par exemple
oui oui il faut absolument que les
actionnaires qui touchent des rentes
sans travailler et bien ne les touchent
plus et que nous autres travailleurs
puissions avoir le salaire qu'ils soient
garantis et puis des investissements
nécessaires aussi au développement de
l'entreprise qui soient garanties a
plutôt que de verser des dividendes aux
actionnaires
alors là le code du travail a été
modifiée par cette loi d'urgence vous
craignez que que ces mesures ne durent
dans le temps eh bien ils sont prévus
pour durer jusqu'à la fin de l'année en
potentiellement ce qui est très
inquiétant parce qu'on peut penser que
la crise sanitaire sera résolu d'ici un
mois ou six semaines
voilà enfin j'espère bien en tout cas et
donc avoir des mesures comme ça qui
aggrave
le temps de travail jusqu'à la fin de
l'année c'est quand même assez
incompréhensible il faut bien voir que
on nous ferait travailler 60 heures par
semaine ce serait un plafond possible et
on aurait plus onze heures de repos
entre deux journées de travail
consécutifs mais seulement 9 heures la
durée journalière du travail pourra être
quotidienne de pointe me porter jusqu'à
12 heures
et puis également sur les modalités de
prise de des congés payés la là aussi il
y aurait des modifications donc on est
quand même très inquiet par rapport à
cela parce que quand il y aura la
reprise j'imagine qu'il va falloir
travailler plus pour redémarrer les
entreprises est ce que c'est ça l'idée
est ce que c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement
rallonger les durées de travail il va
falloir travailler plus pour rattraper
le retard selon vous écoutez rattraper
le retard
oui pourquoi pas mais combien y at-il de
gens privés d'emploi dans notre pays
les statistiques officielles 10 près 3
millions dans la catégorie ya des
chômeurs mais en fait entre 4 5 et 6
millions de gens n'ont pas le la
quantité et la qualité du travail qu'il
voudrait aujourd'hui dans notre pays
donc ce qu'il va falloir pour relancer
la machine après la crise sanitaire
ce sont des embauches et pas
nécessairement une augmentation comme ça
il y est considérable de la durée du
travail
d'autant qu'on a vu ce qui s'était passé
chez chez orange
j'imagine que la crainte c'est
effectivement d'avoir des burn out qui
se multiplient oui effectivement dû du
sauvetage mais aujourd'hui je pense
surtout à nos collègues
enfin à tous les travailleurs les
travailleuses qui sont sur leur lieu
habituel de travail ce qui n'est
quasiment pas le cas chez orange
voilà je pense aux personnels
hospitaliers je pense aux policiers ou
pompiers je pense aux ehpad je pense à
tous ces métiers à et tout ce qui assure
des services publics qui fonctionnent
malgré tout aujourd'hui on l'a
d'électricité on a de l'eau potable
on a tout un tas de systèmes qui
fonctionnent
heureusement d'ailleurs et donc voilà
donc pour nous il est évident que voilà
il ya cette reprise du travail après la
crise sanitaire mais ça ne peut pas se
faire à n'importe quelles conditions
donc pour vous la solution serait de
recruter davantage plutôt que de faire
travailler davantage les salariés ce qui
pourrait temporairement réduire un peu
le taux de chômage voilà voilà il faut
partager le travail puisque la quantité
de travail va être importante
là aussi c'est important par exemple on
parle des saisonnières en parle beaucoup
en ce moment et bien oui voilà dès que
les le danger sera réduit voire annulées
par rapport à la contamination aux
copies de 19 c comme la le sujet
principal qui du moment
effectivement on est dans ce cas là il
faut être attractif ainsi vont avoir des
travailleurs saisonniers qui viennent
sur les lieux de de cueillette ou etc
il faut offrir des conditions de travail
et salaire convenable aussi à tous ses
travailleurs et ses travailleuses
vous pensez qu'on tirera des leçons de
cette crise justement notamment pour le
personnel soignant qui réclament à cor
et à cri depuis des mois de meilleures
conditions de meilleurs salaires vous
pensez que les leçons seront tirées
je pense qu'il y aura un après comme l'a
dit président de la république il faut
il faut préparer le jour d'après
justement et donc je pense que dans un
premier temps il y aura besoin de faire
des états généraux de la santé a tiré un
bilan de ce qui a été fait entre janvier
et mars
notamment ce retard à l'allumage sur la
question de la pandémie
et puis après la halle agissant de la
crise là en plein dedans mars avril
et puis également les années précédentes
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'on manque
d'autant de deux respirateurs dans les
hôpitaux comme encore autant de masques
de protection dans les hôpitaux de gel
hydroalcoolique et cm2
lee ne serait-ce que en réanimation
parce que demain ça y est on va arriver
à saturation nique de france
voilà à peu près 1500 lits en
réanimation ligue de france aujourd'hui
on doit être à 1400 donc il ya une sous
dimensionnement que l'on connaît ici en
france et en ile de france que l'on
connait pas dans d'autres pays comme
l'allemagne la corée ou au japon par
exemple
donc il faut évidemment faire des états
généraux de la santé dans notre pays en
incluant non seulement la fonction
publique hospitalière mais également
toute l'industrie qui lui va falloir
revitaliser en france pour répondre aux
besoins des hôpitaux et donc des
patients mais ça pose aussi la question
des délocalisations puisqu'on n'est plus
capable de produire sur place le minimum
vital
eh bien je ne vous le fais pas dire tout
le monde fait le constat en ce moment
c'est un moment là aussi rare où il ya
une espèce d'unité dans l'analyse tout
le monde constate qu'effectivement tout
c'est un terreau pendant ceux liés au
capitalisme mondialisé protègent mal les
époques les habitants des différents
pays donc oui il doit falloir
relocaliser certaines productions
merci beaucoup benoît martin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france